Good morning, John, let's do a quick overview of our last day of tour just so I can remember it. Here it is.
We've arrived at a place to stop to get food. What is it?
Oh, the usual. I can go to the healthy station. Yeah, you just have a single piece of cheese or...
What, why is that—banana milk?? Is that a real thing? Who are you signing a book for, John?
- Brock's daughter.
- Oh, that's nice.
- Brock, can you be in a video?
- What d'you want me to do?
- Just, I'm just asking your permission to put your face in the video.
- Oh, now you're gonna have to pay me a million dollars. *John laughs*
I haven't said yeah so, if I see it out there somewhere…
[Brock] - Banana milk. I wonder how they process that.
[Hank] - Oh it smells...
[Brock] - Like banana?
[Hank] - Not really. Sniff it. What do you think?
[John] - Did you really say that?
[Brock] - It smells like that, uh, candy.
[John] - Oh yeah, banana 'now & laters'. Oh. Oh god. That's, that smells awful. That smells like fake bananas.
[Hank] - It was in the healthy section
[Hank] - And now we stop for
video making for John's video. Pet area. Does that dog have a crown on it? It's a king dog. His name is Crown.
He's got a poop. John found a real weird tree.
[John] - Weird tree! It like doesn't have a trunk,
It's like a tree made out of dirt!
[Hank] - Ooh, nice chain, John.
Careful, though, don't hurt yourself.
[John] - Thank you.
[Hank] - I mean, Pizza John photoshoot time, look at this chain. Oh, yeah.
Your chain's real dirty.
[John] - I actually don't want this on my body anymore.
[Hank] - Oh, can we actually go into the farm?
[John] - Heck yeah we can.
[Hank] - It's unlocked.
[John] - I mean, that actually is a beautiful...
[Hank] - It's super cool
*cool guy music*
- You ready, John?
- I'm ready, let's do it.
- Last show.
- Aren't you gonna miss the bus so much?
- Hello! Thanks for showing up real early.
Thanks. Oh my god, this is a big place. Hey, there it is, in the basement. These are the books John's gonna sign.
- How you feelin'?
- Good. A little nervous, I'm just going through our questions.
- Oh, we got questions.
- We got questions.
- And we got donuts!
That doesn't happen every night. Thank you to whoever gave us donuts.
[John] - I would now like to bring to the stage for the very first time *laughter*
*laughter* my brother Hank.
Human brains are remarkably flexible. I've been lucky enough to have had a bunch of moments of tremendous
sositive shift in my life going to college, to summer camp, moving to a new place, going on and coming back from tour.
It's amazing how fast I find my brain shifts to accept that this new life is my life now.
And then when I go back to my old life, that life is my life now. That transition is overwhelming, yeah, definitely,
but it also, it's an opportunity to examine my work and what I want to be doing
and I'm very glad to have shared this intense experience with you, John, and with
so many other people and to have made people happy and to just think out loud about what it means to be a person.
But I am also very very very happy to be back home. John, I'll see you on Tuesday
This doesn't feel weird in a pecan orchard at all. People are watching me